the first solar panels were invented in
America in 1954 and yet it's been China
that's been better able to capitalize on
the technology China was one of the
first countries to realize the potential
of solar panels China actually took it
and really commercialized it at a large
scale now China controls over 80 percent
of the global solar panel supply chain
while the United States manufactures
virtually none of the required
components for solar panel production so
to effectively compete with China in
solar panel manufacturing the US is
prioritizing building up its supply
chain basically from scratch
today the U.S has less than half of the
solar capacity that China does and of
the solar panels that are installed in
the U.S nearly four out of five of them
are from Chinese companies China has
such a head start when it comes to solar
panel manufacturing is because they
dominate the entire Global Supply Chain
that's because in recent years China has
spent almost 10 times as much on solar
manufacturing than the US and the EU
combined and of the world's top 10
largest solar manufacturers seven are
Chinese only one is American that Stark
difference plays out in each country's
Energy Mix according to the eia solar
energy makes up 12 percent of China's
total electricity generation capacity
yet it only makes up about 3.4 percent
of the US's total electricity generation
capacity it was really this idea that
they were just going to shoot for the
moon and go big and that has huge
implications and dragged frankly the
rest of the world into this clean energy
as a real option not a play thing
but one key area where the U.S has an
advantage is silica sand the primary
mineral used for solar generation it
exports about 470 million dollars worth
of the mineral and China is the world's
largest importer of silica sand
importing it mainly from the United
States Australia and Indonesia to make a
panel silica sand needs to be refined to
create purified silicon which is shaped
into ingots and sliced into thin Wafers
the Wafers are cut into cells and panel
manufacturers then assemble the cells in
a frame and add circuitry to create a
finished module or panel but even though
the United States has the raw materials
it has no manufacturers of silicon
Wafers or cells used for solar panel
production
manufacturing isn't just some Lego play
right it's about figuring out how to do
something quicker more efficiently
better than others because China is able
to produce solar panels at a
significantly lower cost in global
markets the few U.S solar manufacturers
that do exist heavily rely on importing
components exclusive to China and then
assembling them domestically the reason
China has been able to bring down costs
actually and sustain quality of solar
panels they decided that they were going
to build bigger plants much bigger in
size than the United States had in the
early days they Incorporated new
manufacturing approaches including
Robotics and they were so much larger
with so much less human interaction that
they were able to scale up and this is
actually China's real skill how to make
things and make it commercial viable and
then cheap and accessible
the inflation reduction Act is also the
most significant investment ever in
climate change the inflation reduction
Act passed in August 2022 hopes to
accelerate the transition to a clean
energy economy for solar manufacturing
that means incentives for boosting panel
installations and tax credits for
manufacturing solar components in the
United States
we in the U.S have never had really
industrial policy to support that kind
of manufacturing right it's only now
with the inflation reduction act that we
have the kind of domestic industrial
policy that will support solar
manufacturing and storage manufacturing
here in the U.S already the inflation
reduction act has led First Solar the
biggest solar panel maker in the U.S to
spend 1.2 billion dollars to increase
its U.S manufacturing capacity by 75
percent if we're going to continue to
scale up the industry in order to
address the climate crisis we need to
bring more of that manufacturing home
and we're doing it but because China is
ahead by so much there is debate whether
the U.S should try to invest money in
the sector the United States may not be
able to actually really catch up with
China as much as that it may just be
able to unsure some of the skills so
that it can do it itself I remind people
that energy is used in everything we do
our electricity our transportation our
infrastructure our Communications our
agriculture everything